high burnout rates among nurses during
the covid pandemic led to our country
losing more than 100 000 nurses in one
year that was 2021. in fact that is a
far greater drop than we've seen over
the past four decades kirsten joyce
reports on new research that shows what
kind of changes need to happen to help
our nurses
well-being and also because of
post-covet
robin wubenhorst is a labor and delivery
nurse in southern nevada with 12 years
experience in a career that she loves
this is an amazing opportunity for men
and women
to gives you so much flexibility where
you're not working five days a week
you're working you know like i said for
the most part three days a week in a
hospital but her profession during the
coveted pandemic would place her in
situations with excessive on-the-job
stress well-founded fears of becoming
infected and profound grief over seeing
patients pass away to covet 19. during
the pandemic it was just so incredibly
scary taking care of some of these
patients it was just
a horrific fear on the staff's point of
view because things were changing on
such a rapid
daily basis plagued by guilt when the
mass sick call started coming in torn by
her own personal exhaustion and not
wanting to let the community down i
think everybody's just scared like what
if that happens again what if there's
another pandemic that happens again and
i think this is hopefully for all of us
this is a once-in-a-lifetime situation
is there are problems
in the system problems michelle larkin
says were exacerbated during the
pandemic physical abuse bullying
staffing ratios that don't allow nurses
to provide safe care for the based on
the complexity of the patients that
they're caring for larkin is tackling
our nation's toughest health care
problems with her role at the robert
wood johnson foundation for various
reasons during the pandemic our country
lost more than a hundred thousand nurses
now the foundation says there are key
steps to refilling those roles including
taking care of nurses health and
well-being some of the things that are
showing up in the report
around employers is that they can design
mechanisms for nurses to
be able to
report unsafe working conditions
encouraging a culture of safety which
robin says starts with making yourself a
priority a nurse really needs to
cultivate herself as far as like mental
health and physical health you have to
take care of yourself in order to take
care of your pain kirsten joyce 8 news
now